the debut of Mishra for me has been a
real Revelation he's played here in my
estimation extremely successfully and
yeah uh maturely uh your your your your
take sitting across the board from
Mishra what uh how does it feel for from
from your
perspective well yeah for sure I mean
during the last few years the United
States is a big country and uh we have a
lot of great amazing talents that come
up the scene Amisha is clearly
exceptional he's very talented but he's
also you know I guess hardworking and
very intense yeah you know his father
sure has big plans for him
uh yeah I think he's you know he's doing
very very well he's got a bright future
ahead of him